[Music]
let's go to danielle
oh in my arch-nemesis town
college station what's up danielle
hey how's it going good are you an aggie
i am not ah
danielle
actually i don't i love aggies they're
great too i just went to
i was in lubbock and so you know how
that goes uh how are we doing i'm doing
okay i'm doing okay how are you i'm
fantastic rocking on to the breaking
dawn what's up daniel how can i help
all right so um in april of last year i
attempted uh suicide and i was put in a
mental facility for
a couple of weeks or so um
so
the main thing i'm struggling with is
i feel like i'm stuck in between
two different people like who i was and
who i'm trying to become
um
i've got two best friends one particular
that i've had for over 25 years
and ever since this happened there's
i just feel like no connection you know
it's like um
the friendship and everything is stuck
in the past and there's no way to move
forward we barely text you know a couple
of sentences here and there
um one of them is actually the one that
found me that day
um
so
i just i don't know what to do to move
forward and i also feel like i'm pushing
them away as well
um
i just feel really
really stuck and i don't i don't feel
any connection whatsoever yeah well
i'm glad that you're
let me say this i'm glad that you're
with us
thank you
are you glad that you're with us
yeah yeah yeah most days yeah okay good
um i'll take most days today
um but i'm glad that you're with us on
all days
college station needs you
that's what i'm saying
um
so you as you were describing this just
at the very beginning like i feel like
i'm stuck between who i was and who i
want to become
the first like that's so it's poetically
stated
like that's such a beautiful way to
state that
and
right when you said that the first thing
i thought was
this is going to be about the friends of
the past and
loneliness in the future right because
often who we are is our culture it's the
people we spend time with it's the
things we do the things we think are
funny and now we're transitioning to
here's who i want to become and then our
friends don't always go with us and
that's hard right
um
so i want to give you some peace and let
you know that you're in an exercise
program
and you are right in the middle of it
where you feel good about going to the
gym
and these pictures that you put on your
fridge
on your manifest board or whatever you
don't quite have giant muscles like that
but you're on the way and right now
you're just tired and it doesn't feel
good anymore it's just boring to get up
at 5 a.m and go to the gym every day
that's where you are in terms of this
new light right
so
where you are is absolutely normal i
know that's both like oh good and that's
not good
i don't want it to be normal
um
very very common
with
friends who are walking alongside
somebody who
um
tries to die by suicide
there's trauma involved there especially
if you said your friend found you what
did she find
how did you try to take your life
um
alcohol and drugs okay so did she find
you passed out somewhere
yeah basically okay um i can tell you
i've been in that situation where i walk
in a place where someone has
taken a whole um a whole lot of pills
and drank a lot to where they're
unresponsive
and i do this i did it for a living
where i go in people's houses and
it's scary a couple of those are lodged
into my head forever and i wasn't best
friends with them okay so i tell you
that to tell you this
there's just an awkward like i she saw
some stuff
that scared her and a lot of us don't
have tools on how to enter back into
relationships there
yeah she she definitely
she's she's the type that doesn't deal
well with this kind of thing at all just
to begin with yeah
so
here's the question you have to ask
yourself you've got 25 years with this
friend is this a friend that you value
that relationship like you would love to
see it um not come back to the way it
was because it will never be the way it
was but it could be so much better right
so is this a relationship that you have
interest in growing into the future or
are you just coming to terms with it's
it's kind of played itself out
no i mean she's she's like a sister my
my eight-year-old daughter you know
considers them family or we've always
been she watched my daughter while i was
in the hospital oh wow because my
husband was you know
just so taken back and could barely keep
himself together she helped out with
that okay
um
you may have already done this but
here's what i would do if i was you this
is the best advice i can give you just
what i would do
i would take my friend out
and go get coffee or go get breakfast or
i might save my money and go get a nice
meal
and at the meal say hey
um
i was ready to not be here anymore i was
ready for the pain to stop
and you saved my life
and i also
because of me you saw some really hard
things and i'm sorry i'm so glad you
were there to help me
and um i love you and i value our
friendship
um and i've noticed that we're just
disconnected i want to invite you back
in to my heart and into my life i will
never do that again but i also know
there's going to be some friendship
healing there
and
i'd love i'd love to do that with you
all right
here's what this does number one it lets
her know that you know
that
um she saw some hard things
she
she you scared her right
yeah um and she saw some hard things and
she had to see some things and do some
things that she never dreamed she was
gonna have to do so by you calling that
out it kind of clears the air right like
i know that you know that i know that
you know right
and then the second is telling you i
love you and i know that now things are
awkward so i'm just addressing the
elephant in the room there's a huge
elephant in this room and then yeah the
third thing is
i'm willing to build something beautiful
with you moving forward if you are
here's the scary part of that last one
she may say no
yeah
and i i had a um i had a uh like a a
one-year celebration type thing just for
staying sober and everything
um but she was the only one that didn't
show up yeah
i would not take that personal
okay
okay that wasn't about you that was
about her
okay and you know as a part of recovery
from addiction
is
you can control what you can control
which are your thoughts and your actions
and that's it
and i'm not going i'm going to choose to
not take personal what other people do
to keep themselves well and to keep
themselves safe
and so for whatever reason
she felt like um
i won't be okay if i go so i'm gonna
stay here
all right
and man what a great friend that you
know loves herself
is self-aware enough to not come blow
your party up in your celebration up
with her
her the things she's struggling with
right
yeah true pretty cool
and
you could take that as she loved you so
much that she wasn't going to do that
for your party
but it wouldn't surprise me if she still
has pictures of you in her head crashed
out on the floor and not responsive and
her screaming and her trying to get you
to wake up like in the flashing lights
all those things i've been there and
i've seen it and it's a lot
and so it's just honoring that oh yeah
she's been through she's been through
hell and thank god she did because she
saved my life
and i'm gonna i'm just gonna put that
out on the table
i'm going to tell my friend i miss her
and she might look at you and say i just
can't i can't get back to where we were
i feel like you violated our friendship
you didn't call me like whatever and
she gets to do that and my guess is
she'll heal over time
um but i think you having that
conversation is going to be really
important
okay
i think it'll be a gift to you it'll be
a gift to her because at least you won't
be a limbo anymore
right you'll know right yeah that's what
it feels like but i've talked to her a
little bit um
about it um
but she just
she doesn't she can't really talk about
it she just says you know it was hard
and and then that's it like she's just
done with the conversation which i
totally get
um but i just feel like
it's just always there like it's just
always hovering and it's
and you know i don't drink anymore
obviously um and you know she does and i
just feel like
are we ever gonna reach that point where
we can be friends and not have this
past but only see like the future
and
not you know feel
like man if we were drinking this would
be so much easier exactly right
hey let's let's call it out it would be
so hard if y'all both had a few drinks
y'all could get to the core issue real
fast right yeah yeah and everybody knows
that
that's the importance of going back to
what i told earlier that's the
importance of you setting this on the
table first
right and when you not you but when we
enter into hard conversations and we ask
the other person like
you know why don't you tell me you're
not talking to me we're making it all on
them
and so there's something about you
sitting down and saying hey you saw me
sprawled out on the floor
and i can only imagine that those
ambulance lights are burned into your
brain
and you picking me up and me just being
limp there and you wondering if i was
dead and you trying to find the phone
like
put a couple of details out there
yeah and let her know that you know that
what she experienced was really hard
and let her know that you love her
all right
and it may just be time to take a break
and you'll grieve that and you'll mourn
it but also you'll also be grateful for
the 25 years y'all had together
right and by the way let's take the
let's take the suicide attempt off the
table
it's very very common when somebody goes
through um when they someone goes
through recovery and gets sober
that they
have they lose their friends
because there's a lot of a lot of us
that can't not a lot of us but a lot of
folks who cannot manage social
situations without alcohol
yeah and they don't know what to do
your sobriety is a challenge to the way
they have to get through their day they
feel like
yeah but do you see how that's their
issue not yours
yeah i think so yeah
i know it's easier said than felt right
like i can say it all like that yeah
yeah it's your problem but it hurts
um tell me about this little baby girl
yours
um
she's uh
she'll be nine years old this year yeah
um
you know she's the light of my life
of course it's beautiful
oh yeah
definitely
and my husband um
you know those two are the reason i get
up every day for
sure okay i'm gonna tell you a few
things and i want you to hear me really
really carefully okay
um
you are the reason they get up every day
yeah
and that means you're worth being loved
and you are loved by two of your
favorite people in the world the one
person that's struggling to love
danielle right now is danielle
yeah okay
so here's what i want you to do
i want you to
get a brick
and i want you to put a piece of masking
tape or duct tape on it
and write the first six years
just write the first six years on it i
want you to carry it around for a little
bit
because here's my guess tell me if i'm
wrong
that now that you're sober
you're you celebrated a year recovery
uh april was a year i mean and honestly
i count it but i don't count it because
i'm on medication too oh sister count it
count it i'm counting it you don't have
counter i'm counting
medica medication doesn't count goofball
um yes count it good grief
um count it um
but i want you to carry a brick that
says the first six years because my
guess is
now that you're sober you look back at
the first six seven years of that little
girl's life
and you beat yourself up mercilessly
stop
stop
okay
i want you to carry that brick around
for about 20 or 30 minutes and then i
want you to go set it somewhere in the
corner of your backyard and never pick
it up again
okay
because the greatest gift you can give
there's nothing there's a period at the
end of that sentence it happened
what that little nine-year-old ray of
light is looking for is mama
and she sees her every morning
right
right yeah
and she's saying hey mom let's go let's
go forward let's go this way
same with husband too is that right
yeah yeah for sure you like that guy too
oh yeah i love him more than anything
yeah does he have a mustache
he's got a beard
okay that's fantastic i support that i
don't know about these mustache guys
that are coming back yeah yeah no
yeah
um
it's gonna be a season getting a new
community okay
and
it's gonna be
super important for you to continue to
remind yourself
that
other people's decision to not join you
in an event and a thing that's their
choice not yours
okay that's their challenge is not yours
okay they get to make that choice and
it's not a reflection of you it's a
reflection of them
and that's okay
okay like of all the brave people i talk
to on a regular basis on this show
you're at the very tip top
because what you've done is real real
hard
yeah
and you've got strength that very very
few people have and i want you to i want
you to know it's an honor to talk to you
thank you okay
um
with all of your old friends you know
there's some that i need to be done with
i don't need to be in a relationship
with them and when you get lonely it's
easy to call them back right so we're
staying away from them
are you still seeing a counselor
i guess you're still you're still taking
meds you're still seeing somebody
i'm still on meds um i see i have a
counselor but i haven't seen her since
probably february or january okay
um kind of stopped going yeah let's
reach back out here's what y'all gonna
practice you're gonna practice um making
new friends because that's hard and it's
miserable and it's terrible yeah i don't
want to do that i know but you have to
you have to
and
i think you do want to
you don't want to get rejected you want
to go through all the awkward and weird
and one day you're gonna have to explain
yeah i am in rehab whatever let's wear
it
do i have to do that though i think
that's what i'm afraid of it was meeting
people like
do i need to tell them my past i feel
like i do but i mean not like hi my name
is danielle i used to be an addict
oh no yeah but
i don't know i just feel like this is
such a huge
part of me like
i want it to go away but at the same
time i don't because it reminds me you
know and i don't know if that's the
right way to feel about it or not
you're wearing this as an identity
you're wearing your shame as i am i feel
like it identifies who i am it doesn't
what identifies you as who you are
is the joy you bring into a room
and the hugs you give that little
nine-year-old girl
and that scruffy
bearded husband of yours
when he digs his face into your neck
and you going to whatever church there
in college station and just putting your
head down and holding your hands up and
saying this is bigger than me
going for a walk there in texas when
it's a billion degrees and saying oh
yeah um
right you see i'm saying like that's
your identity
you are not the worst thing you've ever
done
you're not ever stop feeling like it is
is it hard but when you stop calling
yourself that
okay
no it's not going to magically just quit
you've got to stop talking to yourself
that way and then you've got to live
into a new identity
right yeah
so yeah that makes sense here's how it
works it's not
um i'm a former addict who
almost died by suicide because i needed
the pain to stop i needed to stop i
needed to stop
that's you saying this is who i am
or
dude i'm a mama who loves her kids and
loves her husband and the best way i can
love my kid and my husband is by loving
myself
and making sure i take care i'm a i'm a
person who takes care of my body i'm a
person who takes care of my head my mind
i'm a person who has lots and lots of
friends
the person who's got this clock
it's like you're looking up and you see
dark clouds
yeah constantly but you don't realize
that when everyone's looking at you they
just see a tiny little cloud over your
tiny little head and it's raining just
on you
because the sun's out everywhere
well yeah
[Music]
and when you choose a new identity which
is now there's sunshine out here
hard stuff man hard stuff and you're
chilling out your brain chemistry and
working through all those things i'm
proud of you you're still taking your
meds keep doing that
um oh yeah i wouldn't make it without
them
hey don't apologize for that
like that's not that's not a step down
you're not a lesser person you're not
some kind of somehow weaker because of
that
they'll tell you that crap on instagram
but you're not there's a billion people
who have heart transplants that have to
take anti-rejection medication for the
rest of their lives it keeps them alive
and it gives their kids a dad
yeah that's true and it gives their moms
right i mean gives them somebody to
cheer for graduation because mom's still
around
take your meds with a smile on your face
you live in a sliver of history
where they've created some paths forward
for us that are pretty amazing
right
right it's awesome
congratulations and my guess is over
time
depending on what what
what um
psychiatric challenges you're wrestling
with
a new community a community of people
who love you that you can be fully
yourself
and lean into your new identities
dealing with some of the traumas from
your past
and creating new memories for you and
your husband and your kid and new ways
of being
that your body will begin to heal much
quicker than you think
okay
all right so stay on the line i'm gonna
send you a copy of on your past change
your future it's i want you to read it
and i want you to let me know what you
think about it okay in fact i'm gonna
send you two i want you to read them
with your husband oh you got it i have
it and i haven't i haven't been able to
finish it
i i read about halfway through and i had
to stop there you go you know the back
half is right is what do you do next
yeah
it's time yeah yeah
yeah you're right
is it cool
will your husband read it with you
well yeah if i ask him we will okay
let's do this i'm gonna send you another
one and i want y'all to read it together
and you can start over at the beginning
and just make a breakfast date
once uh once a week or once a month
you're going to talk about the latest
chapter you just read
okay and some of it y'all will disagree
with
that's not true that's fine
but when you get to the
um
hey this happened
this happened to me
and here's the other story um struggling
with addiction you you went through some
stuff when you were younger didn't you
oh yeah yeah
i've i've completely stopped
thinking and this has been several years
um
i completely stopped thinking when
someone tells me that they're in
recovery
it's like i can't believe you did drugs
you know you
my thoughts are
wow
what happened that was
i can only imagine what happened that
was so ugly and so hard
that this was the best you i mean this
was the best path forward to you just so
you could get up every day
right yeah yeah so
those things happened
and we're going to feel them and we're
going to own them they happened they
happened they happened
and then we're going to ask ourselves
the scariest question any of us can ever
ask which is what do we do now
right right
and the cool part is that what you do
now is pretty simple and the not cool
part is man it's really hard it's really
hard
right yeah yeah
right
i'm so so proud of you
thank you
and i don't lie on the show i lie a lot
in my personal life just kidding i don't
really um but i don't lie on the show
i'm proud of you what you're doing is
really strong and
my hope is next time we talk
you're gonna say i'm the reason i get up
every morning
because i love me
and i love being on the wake up roll and
i love the sunshine outside and it
doesn't ever rain in texas but one day
it might and you can love the rain when
it happens and you're gonna love your
husband and you're gonna love that
beautiful daughter of yours too
yeah right yep right yes
you're in it for the long haul
i am yeah definitely you're never going
to hurt yourself again
no
say it with confidence
no
not
good
if you're in it for the long haul i am
too
i'll walk with you any way you need over
the next however long until they cancel
the show okay
i'm proud of you holler at me if i can
never help with anything or walk to
anything have your husband give me a
shout um if he ever wants to okay proud
of you proud of the
man your husband sounds great it's just
amazing it's amazing i'm glad that
you're with us
you my sister danielle from college
station texas are not a burden
all of our lives are better because
you're still here